[Music]
a self-described red bull addict
led las vegas police on a chase which
reads reach what stephen green that is
just all he's a monster addict different
brand thank you which reached speeds of
up to 100 miles an hour
mini cooper and officers say that she's
she pepper sprayed an employee during a
robbery wow
they also were found
in the vehicle they had hundreds of
empty red bull cans hundreds
after they were pulled over during the
high school
she also has diabetes dude they were
getting wings bro they were messed up
dude 100 damn she was driving 100 that's
so dangerous i know
people go there for vacation and it's
like you know and there's a ton of
pedestrians so if she loses control
she's smashed into people so two
witnesses on july 20th
shopping at the costco
right two employees uh who were at the
costco witnessed a woman later
identified as the red bull addict
uh stealing a shopping cart full of red
bull cases estimated to be worth about
one hundred dollars she steals them too
well she probably like has no more money
left from all the red bull she's drank
probably dude she's got wings though she
got wings if she consumes more red bull
than steve her hourly pay then that
means she's gonna run out of money oh
yeah that would be bad she's like hey i
if i drink like 200 ripples per hour but
she's like i don't make 200 ripples per
hour i got to start stealing 200 per
hour
an employee attempted to intervene when
she then threatened to pepper spray her
and then her accomplice who was trying
to help her with the burglary got out of
a car and dragged the cart full of red
bull close to the vehicle the woman then
pepper sprays the employee and then they
both drove off and started the high
speed chase damn i'm amazed that someone
like that even has an accomplice yeah
like do you still have friends they both
love red bull though they love red bull
it's like kind of like how crackheads
become friends because they have a
common passion but if you're going to
steal from a costco
you're only i'm gonna steal a hundred
dollars worth red bull dude
like they have computers in there
they've got diamond rings in there
that's some messy behavior she's not
thinking right all you gotta do is go to
one of the many red bull sponsored
events that are happening worldwide it's
free at these pull the whole [ __ ]
card away go to vidcon
yes
it's a cylinder like [ __ ] thing just
pass in the mouth or take the
the red bull car on a mini cooper
that's smart that's a big can of red
bull yeah that's a big one does a does
red bull specifically have like an
addictive property in it caffeine
okay so i don't think it does is it
caffeine
caffeine itself is addictive i haven't
had a red bull in over eight years
really 80 milligrams maybe nine why do
you know that
i don't drink red bull oh i like it why
do you know how many years because i
haven't tasted one in that long dude how
do they not die
from all the [ __ ] cat
dude
you know they drank it all in one
sitting or anything yeah we don't know
have you guys ever tried uh lipoviton
what what
type it up
is that friend elations again
foundations
that's a great shoe dealer
is this just you trying to show off how
worldly you are no no no no type it in
l-i-p-o oh yeah it's in english-speaking
countries it's it's it's oh i know
you're talking about
how do you really say it then um
what is it is it french red one i think
it's the original uh red bull really
because um so they used to have that at
the japanese market and then it was like
for health and energy they market it
that way right so they let me have that
as a kid oh my dad used to just buy a
pack of that and then he let me have
that as a kid i used to drink the five
hour energies what does it taste like it
tastes like this tastes like red bull oh
yeah but like a stronger one slightly
almost medicine feel yeah yeah yeah it's
like it's thicker yeah because red bull
to me is watered-down version of that
carbonated watered-down version of it
yeah
i agree because i can't handle bangs
that's 300 milligrams yeah bane's like
i can't handle that [ __ ] it's
concentrated as [ __ ] that's pretty rough
it actually makes my hand shaking oh
dude you can't drink especially like if
you drink that within an hour your
heart's beating on your [ __ ] chest
and you're not used to drinking 300
milligrams in one city also i get [ __ ]
up when i like i take a lot of caffeine
but then my body doesn't like use it
like physically yeah if i'm just kind of
like sitting and i'm it's more of a
mental thing but then yeah my body
starts to react to it i almost had a
pass out
here at jk news when i [ __ ] downed um
well i had a coffee and then i didn't
know we had to get a surprise vietnamese
coffee that day so i downed that
and then in one of the articles my heart
was wrong like this
and i was just trying to like laugh it
off like
i remember that
and then that's why i knew when you had
to go i was like he's having a caffeine
anxiety attack caffeine induced anxiety
but it was because i didn't sleep at all
the night before yeah i had one here too
bro that's where i got my fever i
thought i had covered i was driving home
after this
and i was like i felt hot but not in
like
like when you get the flu and you get a
fever it wasn't that way it was just my
whole body was just hot like especially
my chest did you jack off after no i
didn't i should the first question i was
thinking if you jack off that's like the
breaks to red bull is it yeah you just
go back to sleep interesting like if
it's like you're like oh i actually
didn't need it tonight then you jack off
and it's like
my dog my daughter me i don't know how
about you guys you guys are weird with
your guilty pleasure my doctor that that
day my doctor asked me to walk through
like everything that happened right so i
was like yeah sleep deprivation all that
[ __ ] right and then because i had
caffeine i think that was linked but
then they said they actually were able
to focus on it even more than that
because because anthony was pissing me
off that day
they use a stethoscope like yeah you
have an anthony in your life yeah you
have a friend that pisses you off yeah
so that's what probably what happened
what did he do that day
yeah what did i do that day go ahead
just being a your [ __ ] dancer as
yourself you know hate my [ __ ] your
haters [ __ ] dancer yourself
anthony and me really truly hate each
other in real life it's true yeah
they're not friends they can't stand you
you can't handle it it's a it's a real
thing i'm probably i'm already scripted
by why i'm leaving jk video yeah me too
i just i just think it's so cool that
like so many commenters were able to
figure that out they're really smart
they're really smart they can see right
through the [ __ ] this is why the the
rising popularity of internet sleuths
has been a thing it's because of [ __ ]
like that they're on it dude i'm gonna
leave jk and be an internet sleuth
it's very
profitable
uh so this man enters a business
um
uh recently right so this is this this
is kind of a separate
this kind of a separate incident right
a man with the same description however
as as the sub as the suspects on july
13th so this is a different incident
right
enters a business on charleston and
valley view boulevard so that's like in
nevada
um he steals 20 cases of red bull he
knows where charleston developed i know
where charleston is um he steals 20
cases of red bull when an employee
confronts them he says don't approach me
i have a firearm i will use it on you if
you approach oh [ __ ] and then there's
another related robbery
where the driver uh failed to stop for
police
uh have they noticed that the car
matched the description of one of the
robberies and so they started to
approach it and then the driver failed
to stop for police and a chase ensued
just for red bull just dude this is an
epidemic
man i wonder what a nevada high speed
chase looks like and also compared to
what a texas
high speed i saw one in nevada where
the cop was
shooting while he was driving yeah
because all the rule because all the
rules of engagement are different right
like la it's very like hands off he's a
criminal we we you know i feel like
texas they probably got one of those hog
hunting helicopters like yeah run
[ __ ]
yeah they're probably trying to end it
asap i wonder how they all play out wait
so in nevada a cop like mid chase can
just be blasted no but i know the rules
of engagement are different based off
politics and stuff too you can shoot
them with a gatling gun you can shoot
the tires out with
[Laughter]
50 calories and if if you hit the trunk
and if you hit the whole back half of
the car whatever throw proximity mines
we're aiming for the tires so my old
neighbor um he worked for the sheriff's
department and then we had like a crazy
homeless problem breaking into all the
the new construction and all that stuff
in our um
in in our community and then i was like
dude you're a like police officer
they're doing like criminal activity
like even though you're off duty can't
you just like arrest them or whatever
and goes nah man he goes in
la
uh pr is just as important as doing the
law so he's like the minute i arrest a
homeless person it's police officer
arrests man with mental health so they
can even help the community no so he's
like even though this is my own
community and he goes but i'm like lasd
he goes i even i have to call the city
police because if some [ __ ] happens it's
on the city police not on the sheriff's
department that's why you should have
done citizen's arrest because there
would have been comedian puts homeless
men under citizen's arrest comedian
makes out with homeless man pretending
to arrest him wow
that's a [ __ ] headline a fitness
influencer fitness influencer uses
muscles for justice that sounds like a
jk news article
versus other states don't have that
problem in vigilante news
i um
quit caffeine for four [ __ ] months
not
just been drinking decaf all that [ __ ]
because i wanted to experience what it
was like because i've been drinking
coffee every day for so many [ __ ]
years i didn't even know what it was
like to not have caffeine in my life we
like caffeine joe caffeine joe is way
more liberating joe's just so sick so
fun caffeine predictable you know what i
realized
how much this [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh junebe that's good branding i don't
want to [ __ ] up this [ __ ] [ __ ]
right here
it's a big bowl it's a part of my
personality i agree if i don't have
caffeine i'm a different person a show
of yourself so you've been cutting out
caffeine for last four months
is there any correlation to like all of
our video views also going down yeah
uh-oh my energy
my thought process are you one of those
people that says when you wake up in the
morning you're like don't talk to me
until i get my cup of joe are you one of
those people
i
for a week straight i thought i was
going through like full-on like a
depressive episode and i'm like dude
what's wrong with my [ __ ] mental
health and i realize it's just mad
addiction
and then like afterwards i'm like oh
i feel like focused i feel like tired i
feel like oh i never get tired you know
and then i'm sleeping normal i wake up
normal all this [ __ ] but then something
feels empty like i don't get hype or
like working out doesn't feel the same
and normal things that i used to do like
grabbing a cup of coffee and going on a
hike like it enhances whatever you're
doing even better like writing something
writing a [ __ ] email like when you're
on caffeine it's like this email is the
sickest [ __ ] email i've ever written
you know that's true become like more
productive and then during my whole like
you know research of caffeine and [ __ ]
they say that the renaissance era was
was pushed or the industrial revolution
was also pushed by caffeine
caffeine because of coffee became like a
thing that everyone started drinking
like i said i like caffeine joe so
yeah caffeine joe was way better man hey
i vote yay for caffeine yeah yay for
caffeine all in favor slam the spoon
please
do
[Music]